[Music]
oh man I mean come on the countdown is
on for Trekkies everywhere
the CBS premiere of Star Trek Discovery
is a little over a month away and we
have been with the cast since the
beginning of their galactic journey
starting with its new leading lady
walking dead alum Sonique wa Martin
green sometimes when you are lost
what bring your strangers fan encounter
I think like a gynecologist noticing
right you know like being in the moment
not in the moment I can say not in the
moment it was it was it was in one of my
sort of it was it was it was when I was
pregnant and so it was one of the free
sit-down sort of meeting I got you guys
you know I think she'll end up going
with that guy said he was you know Mike
my son my son's love you you know that
kind of thing and I go the Trekkie
encounters are only going to intensify
as Sonique wa heads at warp speed
towards the September 24th premiere it
said weird that they already are so deep
into the show it's not traveled in space
because we were thinking well maybe the
one who we all but it feels like they've
seen the show we were banding show but
it's part of a long-running legacy you
just get you just get confirmation of
that you just continue to get pieces of
confirmation that this legacy is real
Sonique WA and her Star Trek discovery
castmates all had the same reaction when
it came to their new costumes
nothing wrinkles they make this you know
stand your straight and I'm rank which
we actually I really appreciate you and
it's really like like been a part of my
physicality and then swallow a small tip
if you look pregnant
[Music]
you